I beg your pardon  thank you  it's my first time on a commuter train  what about you every day last ten years  you must know everyone on this train the  regular commuters mostly let's do an  experiment experiment it's just a simple  hypothetical question what's not what  kind of person are you  what if I asked you to do one little  thing would you do it I'd once know what  kind of thing  someone on this train does not belong  you don't know what they look like all  you have to do is find them  why would I do it there would be a  reward for kidding me  don't leave the train before finding  them don't tell anyone about this offer  they're watching me don't make me hurt  someone you loved  I am NOT gonna do this you have no idea  we up against  they don't kill you your family everyone  on that train  he wasn't if you stop this goddamn train  now  you have until next stop to decide what  kind of person are you  you  [Music]  you